what's up guys
lunch money coming to you live uh well
while she's trying to get rich the rest
of us trying to get our lunch money
right
got miss polina here with me violating
the dress code she's in red today
i'm sure she'll have some smart ass
response as to why she's wearing red
what's going on in the world um
not a bunch of great things um more than
16 million americans have now lost their
jobs in three weeks that's 10
of the american population yeah so
unemployment uh
claims came out today on thursday 8 30.
6.6 million
people filed for unemployment 6.6
million last week
and 3.28 million the week before it's
about 16.5 million
uh this is bad it's really bad and is
there a difference because it says that
uh
americans are filing first-time
unemployment claims the 6.6 million so
that does not include the previous ones
this is just these are new
yeah these are new so here's what's
really interesting about this 6.6
million
is the same number as last week my guess
is that actually there's more than 6.6
million that are eligible to file claims
and are trying to
but 6.6 million again this is my guess
is actually the number where the system
tops out if you can't handle more than
6.6 million claims
and that's where you're getting the log
jams and kind of backup et cetera
i think the system's breaking like it
literally can't process more claims in a
week
and that's why we saw 6.6 last week and
6.6 this week
now that might not be right so let's see
what happens next week but if more than
6.6 million people are trying to file
and it's log jammed
that may be why we're seeing the same
number because it just maxes out
also remember this doesn't include uh
gig
economy workers freelancers
self-employed etc
so there's way more than 6.6 million
that are unemployed
in the past week that's just the number
that actually successfully filed claims
also if you're an employee who got
furloughed can you apply for
unemployment
good question i don't know the answer i
do not believe so i think that's part of
furlough
is like you're not eligible for
unemployment but you're also not getting
paid which is kind of really shitty
um but i believe that's how it works so
unemployment continues to rise
uh 16.5 million new unemployment claims
in just the last three weeks
for context at the end of february we
were at three and a half percent
unemployment which was 5.8 million
americans
uh and so really what's ended up
happening here is we've had about
a 4x in total unemployment we've gone
from about 5.8 million
to over 20 million americans are
unemployed right now
crazy that's absurd all right but the
federal reserve don't worry jerry
stockpicker he has a plan to
solve all of our problems what is the
federal reserve going to do
well moments after the drop uh jobless
claims report came out
uh the federal reserve announced plans
to inject another 2.3
wait billion trillion trillion oh my god
that's a typo
trillion did you find a type of typo
what a cnbc article
2.3 trillion dollars it to stimulate um
the economy so is it going to work no
hell no
one is not going to work two don't think
that it's a coincidence that they oh the
jobless claims coming out thursday at 8
30 and oh by the way we might
accidentally also
uh report that there's 2.3 trillion
dollars on the way
right this is all market manipulation
it's all to try to instill confidence
guess what the economy is not going to
recover until people get out of their
homes
as long as we're in quarantine the
economy's not going to recover this 2.3
trillion though
is on top of trillions and trillions of
dollars that they've already announced
i've literally lost count at this point
how many trillions they've announced but
what they're going to do here is they're
going to back up some of the money
for the uh ppp which is the payroll
protection program
that's going to backstop some of that
then they also have created
a 500 billion dollar program to lend
money to
state and local governments remember a
lot of the government
revenue comes from taxes but it also
comes from other things
in the economy so like in new york city
the mta gets their revenue from
ridership if ridership goes down 90 it's
like any other business they don't have
revenue
therefore how do they pay their
operations how do they pay out the
return
on the bonds that they've issued they
get in a liquidity crunch and so what's
happened here is they're going to lend a
bunch of money
to state local governments as well to
help them
kind of weather this storm so my
question is once quarantine
starts rolling uh off
rolling off once we get allowed out yeah
but it'll happen in different
time periods and different locations but
do we actually think that
all these unemployed people are gonna
come into a market that's suddenly
offering jobs probably not right no
remember my guess is 25
of small businesses don't make it out of
this crisis meaning that they just
will have shut down and not come back so
that's 25
of businesses that no longer will have
jobs in the small business now
though some of those made you have small
number of jobs than the ones that
survive have larger number of jobs
whatever
but let's say 25 small businesses don't
make it out so those jobs are gone
then when you look on top of that well
if i'm a large corporation and let's say
that i
uh got rid of um if i'm a car
organization i got rid of 150 000
employees
am i going to hire back all 150 000 am i
going to hire 200 000 people or am i
actually going to say you know what i
think i can
get by initially with only 80 000 and so
it's a net loss of 70 000 jobs
we don't know the answer yet but those
are the things that people have to pay
attention to
yeah yeah definitely what do you think
i don't know if there's a number of
money that's gonna
so the whole money that's gonna would
you agree with me that we can't print
money
to solve the problem we have to go back
to work
i struggle with that because it's like
if you go back to work are you only
making the
health crisis worse forget forget about
the health crisis for a second just to
solve the economy
going back to work seems like the only
solution right okay now there is a
health crisis going on and so we have to
find the solution that can address both
the health and economic crisis at the
same time
that's the holy grail and that's what no
one's been able to figure out has
there been a government that has done
something kind of innovative to try to
stimulate the economy while
in lockdown well they're all printing
money all around the world this is
happening right because because remember
central banks so the federal reserve
only has two tools they can cut interest
rates right or manipulate interest rates
and they can print money and
quantitative easing or interest rate uh
is only
two tools that they have so they're
using all of the tools at their disposal
but they're just not enough right it's
like showing up and saying like wow
i need to hammer a nail into the wall
but all i have is a screwdriver
technically i can turn the screwdriver
out and smack the nail into the wall
but really that's not the tool that's
intended for that that
uh job if you will right what's going on
with 1200 relief payments
are people getting the money they need
lunch money
the government is supposed to start
issuing
checks today uh to people who have
i i think so it's in tears right so
millions of americans should get
these relief payments starting today
uh as the first wave of payouts for
citizens impacted by the corn virus
so the first group will be about 50
million americans
my guess is are they actually sending
checks are they going to do direct
deposit do we know
it looks like they're sending checks
they're actually sending people or the
people who have filed their taxes i
think
they might get it in a direct deposit
but i yeah if you signed up for direct
deposit got it okay so they're gonna
start direct depositing money today
those people should get it pretty
quickly if not today tomorrow uh
1200 bucks 1200 here's the crazy part
1200
is the number that everyone keeps
selling oh everyone's getting 1200 bucks
that's not true though
wait why because only the most
vulnerable the people who made the least
amount of money get 1200
but as you move up in the tiers you get
less and less money okay
yeah right like you could get a 600
check or 800 check depending on how much
you made and then people over i think
it's a hundred thousand dollars get
nothing
and we've talked about this before but
it also doesn't matter the location
where you live so somebody in new york
city versus somebody in the middle of
georgia would get the same
check all based on your income all based
on your income regardless of where you
live yeah so it's somewhat
right like this person doing the same
job in new york technically should get
paid more than the person in georgia
that's how
generally it works not every time so if
you're getting paid 80
000 in new york city and you're getting
paid 50 000
in georgia depending on where you fall
in those tiers you'll get a
uh an equivalent um stimulus check to
that right yeah
so while we were talking i was actually
doing research and i wanted to see what
the average cost of rent in america is
so the national median rent for one
bedrooms
was is about one thousand dollars
so for a one bedroom the median is a
thousand dollars which means that
one payment could basically be enough to
cover rent maybe
some groceries right that's that's one
month one time
one time so what do you do if this lasts
for
six months well so if you lost your job
remember you can get the
one-time 1200 payment then you can get
unemployment and they beefed up
unemployment a little bit as well
so in some cases you will be able to get
70 80 90 maybe even 100
of your salary right that you lost
you'll be able to recoup through
unemployment
and the beefing up with the relief
payment et cetera
but for many people they won't be able
to do that and
especially if let's say that all of a
sudden you've got a freelancer
and a gig economy worker you've got a
two income household
you've got two kids you've got a
mortgage payment uh and you live in a
city with
um very high cost of living right right
well if both of those people lose their
jobs or they see like a 90
reduction in the income that they make
all of a sudden they're not eligible for
unemployment and they're only getting
1200
each let's call it right you just can't
survive for that long
it's pretty crazy i just i i just think
it's going to be a whole mess because i
think some people are not going to get
their
uh checks and then there's going to be a
backlog of that
so we'll see in canada i believe that
they're getting
two thousand dollars a month for four
months wow i think is the number uh i
may be wrong on that don't hold me to it
but it's
it's one they're getting more money per
check and also it's for a multiple
months in a row
whereas the u.s is a one-time payment
australia the same thing etc
uh do not be surprised if we don't see
future stimulus packages so there's
already talk of this one's called care
there's care 2 care 3 care 4 whatever
in the future i just don't know will
they keep giving money to the people or
they keep bailing out wall street
because while while she's trying to get
rich the rest of us trying to get our
lunch money right what's trying to get
that lunch money okay so let's talk
about your favorite person on earth who
is not me
um federal reserve chairman jerome
powell said thursday that the economic
rebound following the coroner's inducted
induced
shutdown can be robust despite the sharp
downturn so a lot of people talk about
this v curve sort of thing where
economy crash but it's going to like
come back really strong v-shaped
recovery
v-shaped recovery which means literally
right down no i got it and immediately
back up
i got it what are the other ones
u-shaped
correct exactly what does that would
look like like a u
okay what else there's one other letter
that people talk about uh
l shapes s s which is basically like a l
okay right because s basically means
that it just keeps going down
oh yeah right and there's no actual
recovery it just continues down
so wait wait do you want to do your meme
and your sound
he's just printing baby i listen to this
day and night jerome powell is drunk
it's official he's drunk he's absolutely
nuts drunk on
money on stimulus nice he's absolutely
drunk there is zero chance
zero mark it down zero percent chance
that the economy's gonna have a robust
recovery immediately
how are you going to have a recovery
while people are sitting at home is he
sure about this
there's two reasons why saying it one
he's the uh
federal reserve chairman he has to say
this it's all a confidence game i have
to give people the confidence
to continue to go and spend money not to
save don't go take your money on the
bank all the things that drive
confidence he has to say it has two he's
rich as [ __ ]
people don't realize this jerome powell
is got tens of millions of dollars
he's the richest person at the federal
reserve board of directors a lot of
people don't know that
so what i want to know is what's jerome
powell doing in his trading account
is jerome powell long the us economy
right now
we don't know but that would tell us a
lot about what he actually thinks what
has he done over the last four weeks
did he sell stocks did he buy stocks
what was he doing
i don't know but are you okay
no fire away fire away are you allowed
to play in the stock market if you're
the
feds of course you are you could do
listen these people are all doing this
right they're supposed to report it
there's all kinds of different things
depending on your role
president maybe i want to be the fed
chairman if you were the fed chairman
guess what it's like having a bank
account you can just go in and you just
edit the amount you have there every day
like oh i have 2 trillion now i have 3
trillion let me ask this when
in the last time in the uss history has
there been
a v uh a v shaped recovery
uh there was a crisis the the big one
that i know of i think it's 1990
i want to say don't hold me to that
right after the spanish flute
yes there was a uh economic crash but
there was
no um interference or manipulation by
the government the government did not
step in there was no stimulus etc
and there was a very quick recovery uh
and then we
went for like 10 years of positive
growth and then we went to the great
depression
right but since then after the great
depression when the government stepped
in and started to manipulate things in
the federal reserve treasury et cetera
uh they've always done that and so there
hasn't been the v-shaped recovery like
if you remember in 2008
2007 problems kind of sort of started
2008 liquidity crisis
and then it took until 2009 2010 and
into 11 for the full recovery it
actually happened
so it was very much this very long
u-shape so here's my question
how can he say when the spread of the
virus is under control businesses will
reopen and people will come back to work
given that ten percent of the population
is out of work
ten percent of labor force definitely is
out of work right the rest
well the businesses when the spread of
the virus is under control they will say
okay you can open your business now
right so businesses will open so
there will be there will be a growth the
question is is that
what's the trajectory right is it do we
go from hey we lost 30
or 20 of gdp back to it flat of where we
were
no it's probably still going to be down
from there but what they'll say is hey
we have 10 growth in gdp this quarter
right
well yeah but it's 10 after you lost 30
you know percent
right so it's look it's all a confidence
game as we have to remember is his job
is to say
exactly what he's doing uh and the only
tools he has is he can manipulate the
interest rate
he's gone to zero if he wants to go into
negative interest rates he could but
that's a very
kind of religious topic meaning that
it's very sensitive people have a lot of
opinions it's politicized etc
uh so you can print money and they're
they're printing [ __ ] trillions of
dollars
i just don't know if they're gonna be
able to print their way out of the
property i really hate that everything
is so politicized like imagine if
politicians would be able to put
everything aside and be like okay listen
what is the best thing we can do for the
american people right now
i don't care if i get reelected i don't
care if i
why are you using common sense common
sense isn't allowed this is politics
baby
common sense ain't allowed you see the
dikembe mutumbo finger wagon
all right let's go robust recovery
speaking of politics
speaking always just that no i know
speaking of politics we're going to talk
about joe exotic
okay it was carol [ __ ] baskin
another thing i've been listening to day
and night um i mean you guys gotta admit
like
i think that somebody should do a
stand-up routine and that's the whole
pitch of the thing every time you talk
you're just like
plana walked in slipped on the floor and
it was carol
[ __ ] baskin no one would laugh at
that
literally all right what's going on with
jokes i gave him a pity laughs yesterday
he was like see you would laugh oh there
he is
um when your tiger king documentary gets
the carol baskin murder case reopened
it was carol [ __ ] baskin okay so fun
fact for you guys
34 million people watched the joe exotic
documentary in the first
10 days it was on netflix are you
impressed by that it's a number one show
for two weeks
that's insane i saw an article that
talked about how like it would have been
a boom for movie theaters if they were
open and if it had gone in you know why
movie theaters are closed
because they don't need your germs it
was carol [ __ ] baskin
see she's laughing that's all i'm saying
i cannot hear out of my right ear all
right let's go joe exactly what's going
on with joe exotic okay
so this reporter who is apparently doing
like the lord's work
uh decided to go to a press conference
about coronavirus
and ask trump what was it
if he that that dawn no he said
are you considering pardoning joe exotic
and trump acted like he'd never heard of
tiger king
but he then said well what did he do and
they said he'd try to get a woman killed
and
trump i will give trump this one thing
he tried he tried to get the journalist
in trouble he said uh well what do you
think should be pardoned and the
journalist very intelligently said i
have no opinion
and trump said of course you don't
because if you did then you wouldn't be
an unbiased journalist
and so my favorite part of the whole
thing though is on the next question he
points to a report and goes uh what
questions do you have uh what do you
think about this
and the guy's like i have no opinion but
i do like joe exotic
and trump's reaction when he hears the
guy's name is joe exotic because
joe exotic that's the thing okay alright
guys your question
like he may do it i don't know do you
think he should
oh i'm a journalist i'm not biased
uh do you think that joe exotic should
be
exonerated i think it should be exotic
look the whole thing here is uh is
absolutely hysterical like this is
literally
out of a tv show the fact that we have a
real life journal it's like a legitimate
journalist
asking the president about joe exotic
because don
jr said something about it the day
before so of course he's gonna ask
well and trump knew immediately which
one of his sons said it he's like it was
dawn wasn't it
hey listen uh mike novogratz tweeted at
me and said trump would lock up the
election right now if he
uh if he came out and he pardoned joe
exotic
uh novogratz said that uh immediately
trump would be the winner i saw i saw a
meme that said
literally the only two conversations
you're having right now
are about either about chronovirus or
joe exotic there's nothing else there's
nothing in between that is
that is it you know why right why it was
carol [ __ ] baskin
she laughed again all right guys that's
it today for lunch money
we will see you tomorrow remember while
while she's trying to get rich the rest
of us just trying to get our lunch money
right
and we will come to you every day
noonish why ish because we don't have
our [ __ ] together before noon afternoon
right at noon or
at 5 00 p.m paulina continues to behave
she continues to be kind she continues
to be funny
because it was carol [ __ ] baskin
so we will see you guys tomorrow